das ja wie minecraft hier nur ein
bisschen mit schießen genau mein gott
freunde egal auf welche internetseite
man derzeit geht es sehen immer dort
artikel über fortnight was ist fortnight
[Musik]
das war die frage die ich mir vor
einigen wochen gestellt haben habe dann
ein bisschen recherchiert und abgesehen
okay das ist ein neues spiel für
computer für places gibt es mittlerweile
für alles ich werde das nicht spielen
dann habe ich mir videos angucken dachte
das sieht eigentlich ganz cool aus dass
ich jetzt mein charakter laser luca 69
wenn nämlich da enden wollt dann macht
einfach bitte nicht auf jeden fall habe
ich dieses spiel wirklich noch nie
gespielt aber ich würde sagen wir
kriegen einfach mal auf bereit steht
hier unten spielersuche und das lädt
erst mal irgendwas runter ein paar
sekunden später kopfschüsse richten
erheblich mehr schaden an ziele auf den
kopf ich hoffe ich kriege es denn
überhaupt auf irgendwen zu ziehen also
so wie es aussieht befinden wir uns
jetzt hier im spiel das unter mir ist
erde ich weiß ich kann ich die abbauen
luca wir sind hier nicht in minecraft
die tür öffnet sich in fünf sekunden
also sieht so ein bisschen so aus als
wäre das ganze hier partie wir reisen
jetzt hier mit einem essen bus also ich
weiß nicht ob ich jetzt irgendwie schon
rausspringen soll die anderen springen
alle die ganze zeit raus aber ich will
ja nicht direkt sterben aber ich gehe
jetzt einfach mal lehrt hass und jetzt
springe ich hier runter mit leertaste
kann ich den hängegleiter einsetzen also
jetzt wow gut luca jetzt kämpfen lauten
schon alle und ich hänge in der luft
oder war s 2000 jahre später nach 2000
jahren komme ich jetzt auch so langsam
auf dem boden also meine damen und
herren ich bin jetzt hier das kann ich
hier rumlaufen ich kann springen ich
kann schlagen ich kann der rechten
maustaste gar nichts machen aber jetzt
haben wir schon mal hier gegen und jetzt
sehen wir die dings geht runter und
bahnen
jetzt hat den personen die gewohnt einen
tollen wintergarten
was haben wir denn hier freunde revolver
okay jetzt habe ich den revolver dann
ziemlich mal die munition auf jetzt kann
ich wechseln und habe jetzt den revolver
ko mein gott kann ich damit den
kühlschrank
oh mein gott ich weiß nicht wer hier
wohnt aber die person hat jetzt keinen
kühlschrank mehr zeugnis man jetzt kann
ich eher drücken da lädt diese person
hier irgendwie nach ich weiß wo mein
gott es sieht nach einem ganz ganz bösen
sturm aus ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt
irgendwie machen muss ich habe hier eine
pump gun oder was ist das hier vorne im
moment die hier habe ich jetzt in der
hand wie kann die hier kann ich hier mit
eigentlich dahin ich weiß nicht ob ich
gute kribbeln oder ob ich schlechte
kippen
also ich bin halt level 1 oder 0 keine
ahnung das ist das erste spiel was juden
das sieht schön aus dass körper neue
windows hintergrund werden wir vorn
haben im bild also wenn wir hunger haben
könnt mit theoretischen pilze essen war
schon habe ich dann irgendwie abbauen
kann den pilz rom ein gehaltsstopp der
pilz ist weg oh mein gott ich habe holz
ich habe gesehen dass ich mit meinen
ressourcen waschbar
nein nein ich kann nein ich hab die
berliner mauer gebaut also ich kann mich
jetzt dahinter verstecken und dann kann
ich hier rum geht auch mein gott hätten
die spieler aber ich glaube die sind
hinter dem berg ich sehe es recht dass
ich nur noch relativ wenig holz habe
damit kann ich also keine wand mehr
bauen
deswegen will ich jetzt mal einfach nur
noch hier eben schnell den baum jetzt
habe ich wieder ein bisschen mehr heute
jetzt kann ich wieder auf f1 drücken und
kann jetzt das mal beispielsweise hier
hinsetzen und dann setze ich das mal
hier ich habe schon wieder zu wenig holz
was kannst du eigentlich dass ja wie
minecraft hier nur ein bisschen mit
schießen
hier unten haben wir auch noch einen
baum da kann ich unten auch noch mal
eben kurz ein bisschen mehr holz holen
genau hier den busch kann ich dennoch
irgendwie neben busch gibt mir nichts
schaut mal rosen kann ich die rosen
theorie
das geht auch nicht freuen das leben nur
noch vier leute und ich bin einer von
denen
und wisst ihr woran es liegt dass ich
noch lebe hier an
das ist nämlich mein schutzbunker und
ihr auge des sturms wird kleiner ach du
heilige scheiße ist ja die partie doch
meine damen und herren will wieder
zurück
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich hier wie wie
komme ich wieder raus kann ich irgendwie
toluca super gemacht mit f3 kann ich
eine treppe bauen also habe ich mir
jetzt einfach eine treppe und jetzt bin
ich habe ich das ist wow freunde das ist
ford night at its best
aber wir sind ja nicht hier um häuser zu
bauen sondern um den zu kämpfen und zu
gewinnen weil das ist das was wichtig
ist im leben wenn man so hoch läuft
nicht alles hat mir ganz schön ich außer
guckt man da hin und sieht sowas ist
dass es sieht aus als hätte gott
irgendwie blaue scheiße auf uns noch
genau hast du heilige scheiße nein nein
nein nein
bei gott leiter andrew du du du du
scheiß auge des sturms alter kommen da
war ich kurz auf toilette und irgendwie
nein freunde mein herz geht drunter ach
du heilige scheiße hält auf toilette die
nase zu putzen und dann zieht er mich
hat einmal aufhören die richtige zeit
dicker will wie klein soll das denn noch
werden willst du mich verarschen cool
gott war erst mal hier in fetten sturm
anzetteln und jetzt wird auch noch
kleiner oder was ist ja nicht so dass
ich hier immer irgendwie mitkämpfen will
oder sondern höre ich auf wert ruhig
noch kleiner heute da vorne ist das ende
des sturms alter meine fresse das und
das kann doch nicht wahr sein mein leben
geht so schnell das ist nicht wahr das
ist nicht wahr das ist eine sache von
sekunden das ist das ist wow wow cool
ich liebe dieses spiel
[Musik]
was kannst du eigentlich leibe im auge
des sturms ja das ist mir gerade auch
aufgefallen
wir sind jetzt in der neuen runde
freunde die ganzen anderen vollidioten
da springt schon alle raus immo wir sind
schon bei der ok ich bin jetzt auch mal
eben raus die runde jetzt sollte ein
bisschen interessanter werden ich meine
vorhin habe ich ja erst mal nur so 'oh
mein gott' landen da viele leute ich
meine vorhin habe ich halt erst mal so
ein bisschen gehässig auch mein gott was
vor nicht gegen den stein weil das ist
doch nicht sein scheiß ernst man nicht
den stein irgendwie okay steine kann ich
mir sogar aufholen
vorhin habe ich natürlich nicht ernst
gespielt meine damen und herren weil ich
mein ich muss euch das spiel irgendwie
müssen beibringen und ich weiß nicht ob
ich sonst hätten warum auch fällen kann
ja okay das ist jetzt auch kaputt
gegangen da hinten ist eine hütte
vielleicht gibt es da irgendwelche
waffen die so bin ich eigentlich jetzt
überhaupt man führen euch doch von
hübsche lady ja komm erstmal ne runde
schwimmen da hinten ist ein spieler ich
weiß nicht ob er irgendwelche waffen hat
oder nicht aber der hätte mich auf jeden
fall gesehen und hätte mich töten können
weil ich habe ja gar nichts also was
haben denn hier vorne drin hier haben
wir tatsächlich auch da keine waffen das
natürlich schwierig übrigen story von
meiner haare aber ich bin einfach ein
herzlicher spaß die haben da
irgendwelche autos ich weiß nicht was
ich damit machen kann wollte
wer sich irgendwelche waffen sind wir
sind auf jeden fall weg die ganzen autos
ist sind hier vorne vielleicht waffen
ich glaube in der vorherigen runde hatte
ich echt glück dass ich in diesem
gebäude irgendwie drei waffen gefunden
habe oder so aber wir schauen was sich
darin befindet vielleicht haben wir ja
hier oben die irgendwie waffen drin das
war ganz schön weil dann wie viele
schläge hält dieses teil überhaupt aus
da kommen hier 1000 jahre später haben
wir das ding jetzt auch mal offen und
kann ich da einsteigen
wie kann denn das ist ja nicht gta
machen wir den laden hier auch kaputt
war oh cool haben wir hier jetzt noch
ein paar ressourcen
das ding ist freunde ich brauch waffen
damit ich real supreme xd was sind das
eigentlich alles für komische namen also
ich kann jetzt hier mal was hin warum
dann bei euch hier vorne mal auch noch
was hinten und dann baue ich mal hier
vorne auch noch was hin und jetzt ha mir
kann keiner was haben ja also was habe
ich in dieser runde bisher geschafft
dass hier eine mauer
mir macht es auch schon wieder sehr sehr
viel angst dass da hinten dieser sturm
schon wieder so groß wird endlich weiß
nicht hier vorne wir können uns der fuß
sehe ich will aber nicht zum fuß
gelaufen sondern ich will einfach nur
ein paar waffen finden also hier vorne
haben wir eine waffe eine taktische
maschinenpistole
oh my god die cia sex fakten lager noch
das hier das ist noch eine rauchgranate
ist schon die zweite die ich hier habe
den trecker keine ahnung was sie damit
machen kann das wär halt mega cool wenn
man irgendwie mit den karren noch
umfahren können oder so irgendwie bin
ich tatsächlich immer bei der orten wo
nie andere liest sie warum ihr keine
anderen leute sind bei den 16 sekunden
dieser schadstoffe wieder vorbei als
freunde da hinten sind spieler ich
versuche jetzt mal umzubringen
es sieht so aus als wir dass sie deren
base irgendwie ich weiß allerdings nicht
ob die noch hier vorne sind oder ob sie
schon abgedeckt sind also wir schauen
uns jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen um
hey laufen weil man hier noch die treppe
hoch und jetzt sind wir hier oben
angekommen
hier oben ist niemand hier liegt eine
pistole die kann ich noch mal eben
aufheben aber sonst oh mein gott da
unten läuft jemand freunde sieht ihnen
[Musik]
habe ich mein gott habe ich da jemand
umgebracht scheiße er tut mir leid mein
gott die scheiße du vor den kopf
oh mein gott ich habe schon wieder
jemand getötet
freunde haben das war es jetzt hier
familie meine damen und herren wenn euch
fortnight gefällt das gerne mal einen
leid da schreibt immer in die kommentare
bilder spiel selber auch spielt und
schreibt mir auch in die kommentare ob
ich das noch mal hoch laden soll weil
freunde ich bin der beste fortnight
spieler aller zeiten also wenn ich euch
im nächsten video ein paar tipps geben
soll wie man die besten mauern gebaut
oder wie man die besten waffen findet
oder was die besten spots hin um
irgendwelche angriffe zu machen das gern
like da werde ich euch das im nächsten
video hat glas wasser das war's jetzt
ihr vom video hier können jetzt hier mal
den kanal abonnieren oder hier unten
meinen job ausschenken ihr findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent sein könnt ihr auf die glocken
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]